jack dorsey has given away about a third
of his net worth uh and is publicly
tracking how he's doing a lot of
transparency actually pretty cool uh
yesterday uh people started to realize
jack dorsey's been a little bit more
active on twitter uh over the last
couple of days uh i don't really know
why but i like it it's cool you know
when you see jack kind of firing off
tweets there uh you get excited like hey
the guy who created the platform is
engaging and uh he's not just responding
to uh all the love messages there's a
couple haters out there trolls etc he's
responding to them too he's being pretty
uh
interesting we could say and so
yesterday
jack hinted at something that's very
interesting
there is uh an individual um if i
remember correctly it is
said this is the one thing that feels
like would benefit the eth meaning
ethereum ecosystem way more than it
benefits twitter and they were talking
about the fact that twitter should have
a wallet address for storing nfts users
could select any nft in their wallet to
use as their avatar it would serve as
one of the biggest verified layers for
showcasing and distribution
and so the comment was this is one thing
that feels like it would benefit the eth
ecosystem way more than it would benefit
twitter
jack responded and said
agreed
every account on twitter being able to
link to a lightning wallet however
dot dot dot
and so when you think about this what
jack essentially was saying is if we
connected your twitter account to a
wallet that stored nfts that would
benefit the nfts way more than it would
benefit twitter he's not saying that
that's a bad thing or anything else he's
just saying that that doesn't
necessarily benefit twitter
but he did say however every account on
twitter being linked to a lightning
wallet
and so that immediately got us thinking
well if twitter was to actually do this
it could create one of the biggest
inflection points in the history of
twitter so for those of you that have
listened to content from me for a while
you know that i've been a big believer
that twitter and square will likely
merge at some point in the future and
the idea is that in the western world we
have yet to see
a super app built
from taking a leading financial company
and a leading communications company and
putting them together we have them in
the east in china and elsewhere but in
the west we have yet to see that really
happen and so the idea would be if you
take twitter and you combine it or merge
it with square you now would have a
public forum where conversation happens
in real time people have identity they
have connections a social graph etc and
you overlay it with financial services
that would allow you to pay merchants or
pay for goods and services to be able to
pay each other etc it's an interesting
idea
but all of a sudden when you take it
from the legacy infrastructure rails and
you bring it to the lightning network
which is the layer 2 for bitcoin
you realize that the lightning network
allows for something much much more
powerful the lightning network allows
anyone anywhere in the world to tap into
global infrastructure and send very
small amounts of money the equivalent of
pennies
to anyone else in the world
instantaneous and completely for free
why is that so important to something
like twitter well if you think about all
the financial services that could be
integrated into twitter
it's things around tipping joe has a
great tweet here's a penny or two penny
john
publishes something that i like
and i want to read it and he puts it
behind a paywall john here's 10 cents so
i could read your article micropayments
or
i want to listen to
a twitter spaces and joe and john are on
there roasting each other
maybe i could stream sats while i listen
to the twitter spaces so that they can
make some money while they're doing it
there are example after example after
example where these micro payments could
be super valuable
but you need infrastructure that can
actually process it and so when you
start to think about the legacy
infrastructure it actually is very
difficult to do micro payments it's
expensive and it's slow but when you use
the second layer of bitcoin something
like the lightning network it becomes
very viable and so if jack was actually
to go as far as to link every account on
twitter to a lightning wallet not only
would it serve as a massive inflection
point for both twitter and bitcoin but
it would push us much further
towards jack's vision of bitcoin
becoming a native currency for the
internet if you think of one of the
problems with currency
on the digital
kind of landscape
every fiat currency in the world has
been built to serve as the reserve
currency within a certain geographic
region so in the united states the u.s
economy has the u.s dollar in mexico the
mexican economy has the mexican peso etc
you can go around the world and see this
fiat currencies have been tied to
geographic boundaries and geographically
focused economies
but the digital economy
knows no bounds there is no geographic
boundaries when it comes to the digital
world i can enter into the portal of my
smartphone or my computer and i can
communicate and i can transact and i can
participate hang out with etc anyone
else in the world who also entered into
that digital world through the portal of
their phone or their computer and so if
now all of a sudden geography doesn't
matter
and the
individual
geographic based economies start to fade
into the background and the digital
economy becomes
ultimately the most important what is
the native currency of the internet what
is the native currency of that digital
economy there hasn't been one and that
ultimately is what jack dorsey's vision
for bitcoin is from what i understand
and so if that actually was to occur
now you don't have to worry about
exchange rates you don't have to worry
about multi-day settlement times you
don't have to worry about high cost of
transactions you simply can use bitcoin
and have everything denominated in
bitcoin and have anyone anywhere in the
world accept bitcoin pay in bitcoin
store their wealth in bitcoin etc
if bitcoin is able to rise to become the
global reserve currency of the digital
economy something like twitter being
able to link every single twitter
account to a lightning wallet
would be
an immense move forward for both the
company and the digital currency now
many people would say why the hell would
a big tech company or a centralized
entity like twitter be willing to
integrate with a decentralized digital
currency something they do not control
why would they want to plug into an open
network like this don't these large big
tech companies want control don't they
want to have centralization don't they
benefit from that both monetarily and
also from a implementation of their
vision of course
but jack dorsey is not your normal ceo
jack had a second tweet where somebody
said that big tech is scared of ethereum
ethereum disrupts big tech
and jack so eloquently just said
disrupting big tech is exactly what's
needed and what i want no one technology
alone will do that though and so what's
fascinating about this in my opinion
is that jack dorsey is the ceo of a big
tech company but he understands that we
need to disrupt it he understands the
innovator's dilemma he understands that
if he does not disrupt the current
twitter model then somebody else will
and so you continue to see him work on
things like blue sky which is a focus
of creating a decentralized version
and a decentralized protocol on which
social networks can be built on in the
future you see him focusing on things
like bitcoin which is a decentralized
digital currency and trying to figure
out how can he integrate it into a
service like twitter
jack dorsey understands where the world
is going and jack dorsey is trying to
disrupt himself
and that is usually a very very very
rare position for somebody with such
wealth and power and success to be in
because most people would just continue
to double and triple down on what's
working they would continue to try to
drive as much financial gain as possible
and continue to expand their control
over their mini fiefdom but jack dorsey
understands there's a bigger play in
other tweets that we don't have pulled
up he's basically talked about the fact
that it's not about the money he's going
to donate all the money anyways it's not
that that it drives him he simply wants
to create a better world he wants to
bring social and economic freedom to
people around the world he's not only
doing it in the united states he's
focused on other places like nigeria
ghana etc and
i'm willing to bet that jack dorsey is
going to end up using technology and
create immense leverage for him and his
team to be able to usher a lot of this
change in hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it